but as soon as we write any code that
relies on the differences that exist
between a regular car and a cop car then
we have a bit of a problem we can't
really add a call method to every car
instance because we don't really think
that non cop cars deserve that method
one naive solution would be to copy all
of the code from the car class into a
second class and then refactor it we'd
probably give the two functions
different names to reflect that they are
different classes then in each function
we would add the code that would make
that particular class different from the
other in this case imagine that the grab
method is something only vans should be
able to do because it's the way in which
the van is going to be able to attack
the player by contrast this call method
is something that's only available to
cops because it represents the way in
which the player can get access to help
from a cop in this scenario we would
have two different constructor functions
that both produced objects that were
basically identical with the exception
of this new method either grab or call
this solution works but as you can see
there's a lot of duplicated code here
let's look for a solution that allows us
to reuse that code rather than type it
twice